if you're an xbox one owner in 2017  executive Phil Spencer says you've got a  lot of good stuff coming your way I'm  Tony this is a gamespot news update and  be sure to subscribe for all the latest  on Xboxes 2017 lineup in a post on xbox  wire Phil Spencer talked about his  excitement for the year ahead he said  2017 is shaping up to be one of the most  exciting years ever for xbox gamers we  are preparing to launch the most  powerful console ever made this holiday  project Scorpio along with a diverse  lineup of games in fact we're committed  to delivering even more exclusive games  for both xbox one and Windows 10 this  year then we launched in 2016 Xbox one's  2017 first party lineup includes  crackdown 3 state of decay two and halo  wars 2 and for more on that last one  check out our discussion on the lobby  about how halo wars 2 appeals to  longtime fans for all the latest on xbox  you're already in the right place  you